me
hi I know that you took your daughters
to the reputation tour did you score
tickets to the arrows tour yet
absolutely you did okay
okay so you're one of the lucky few it
helps when you sing on a record that is
true and how soon when you have a couple
of collaborations with the artist and
you can bet 14
Sunday and 12 year old Faith along with
their mama Nicole are just as excited to
see Keith rocking out on stage
[Music]
this four-time Grammy winner just kicked
off its brand new show Keith Urban the
Las Vegas residency at Zappos theater at
Planet Hollywood Resorts and casino on
the website it does tease that this show
is an explosive experience of emotion
and one moment in particular is when you
show the wedding footage of you and
Nicole during without you
[Music]
special is that
is that
um extremely I mean usually it's a good
surprise although now everyone's ready
for that but hopefully everything in the
show is very organic it's hard to talk
about just come and see it yeah just
come and see it you'll be in for a
surprise speaking of surprises Nick did
make a surprise during your last
residency what's your name
oh cool
she excited to come see this one yeah
always what is it about Vegas that keeps
you coming back energy the energy energy
and unpredictability every night is
different I mean one Friday night is
totally different from Next Friday night
so it always feels brand new every night
feels brand new we changed the show just
a little bit you know always to just
keep it vibrant and pressing in the
moment and calibrate the pacing
depending on the room I mean it's about
reading the room between the guitar the
drums bopping around dancing I mean you
must be burning a lot of calories out
there physically prepare for two hours
every night well I mean here's the great
thing about our audience and I think
they get it that if we give this energy
on stage and they give it back to us
this thing just goes and goes and goes
and it's much easier than if everyone
was just sitting and watching for I
couldn't I couldn't do what I do if
everybody sat and watched for two hours
I'd be exhausted and that's probably why
you're adding more dates to The
Residency yeah that's right Keith just
added eight more dates starting in
November what does that downtime look
like to you in Vegas have you been able
to maybe see Adele weekends with Adele
there's not so much to do here there's a
place called dig this that I went out to
last week where you operate bulldozers
you can smash a car with this big they
said a lot of girls do it because they
take their aggression get our energy out
there oh yeah you can pretend that's
your ex-boyfriend's car and annihilate
it okay
[Music]
what about new music is being in this
space back with the fans is that
inspiring music for you at all or yes
always okay all right so what can you
tease about maybe anything the rest of
this year new music
um I've been working on a bunch of new
musics getting uh
most of an album done and get that out
this year literally music to my ears and
then you'll have the dates here to play
the new music yeah look at the way that
works yeah
that's some new things it's quite good
[Music]